صراع التجسس بالسيارات الكهربائيه
صراع التجسس بين امريكا والصين يتفاقم
يوما بعد الاخر
اتهامات متبادله بعمليه التجسس على
المواقع الحساسه والعسكريه في البلدين
ولكن ليس بالطرق التقليديه المعروفه في
عالم الجاسوسيه بل هذه المره عن طريق
السيارات خصوصا الكهربائيه وذاتيه القياده
منها لقد اصبحت هذه الاليات هي المتهم
الرئيسي في النقل البيانات للخارج بدايه
من مكالمه السائق وتاريخ تصفحه للانترنت
حتى الرسائل الشركات المصنعه لهذه
السيارات تقول ان الهدف من جمع تلك
البيانات هو التطوير والتحديث وعوامل اخرى
تتعلق بالامان والسلامه لكننا خفيه قالته
بكين في عام 2017 عندما صنفت الامر
كتهديدا لامنها القومي بعد تخوف فيها من
تقنيات سيارات مثل الامريكيه لدرجه ان
القوات المسلحه الصينيه
خلال البيانات التي يتم معالجتها بواسطه
كاميرات مثبته
سياره تسع بل ان التقارير اشارت الى ان
الجيش الصيني حضر استخدامها هذا النوع من
السيارات بالفعل داخل منشاته مع دفع الى
رد سريعا من جانب مالك شركه ايلون ماسك
اذا ثبت تورط اي شركه في انشطه تجسس على
حكومه اجنبيه فستكون لذلك عواقب وخيمه
تواجهها هذه الشركه
وساغلق شركه تسلا مخاوف الصيني والولايات
المتحده تفاقمت حول سهوله اختراق البيانات
التي تجمعها السيارات ذاتيه القياده خصوصا
بعد ما اخترق شاب الماني اكثر من 25 سياره
في دول مختلفه
استطيع الان اصدار الاوامر عن بعد الى
اكثر من 25 سياره تسلا في 13 دوله دون
معرفه اصحابها ويشمل هذا التحكم في
الابواب وبدات تشغيل السياره بدون مفتاح
في المقابل الولايات المتحده تخشى
السيارات الصينيه ذاتيه القياده الاخيره
صيني لشوارع امريكا ماذا فعل بعض المشرعين
الامريكيين لاطلاق مبادره من اجل ايقاف
هذه السيارات واخفائها من شوارع بلادها
شركه اوتو اكس الصينيه تجري تجارب لسياره
ذاتيه القياده في شوارع سان فرانسيسكو وهي
سياره مزوده بثمن كاميرات تلتقط كل شيء من
حولها ومزوده ايضا بتقنيه الايدر التي
تستخدم نبضات ضوئيه لتوليد معلومات ثلاثيه
الابعاد دقيقه حول محيطها
شيء واحد وهو تهديد البناء التحتيه
الامريكيه والمواقع العسكريه وامن البلاد
القومي حسب ما اشار اليه بعض المشرعين في
الولايات المتحده واعتبروه بمثابه حصان
في بريطانيا عندما تم اكتشاف جهاز التتبع
صيني في سياره تابعه للحكومه البريطانيا